covet vaccines are being made and
distributed across the world
each vaccine needs a vial a syringe
packaging
and a needle a bunch of little pieces to
get the medicine to consumers
and you'd be shocked to find out that
one of the biggest producers of these
little pieces is a family run company
called the steven auto group
founded outside of venice in 1949 they
started out making bottles for wine and
perfume
in the 1960s they were a company that
was really focused
on you know producing for the
food industry um winemakers
and that's sort of a business that was
not really working out for them anymore
as those
switch more to plastic they were trying
to figure out a way to sort of
move away from the food industry and and
try to
find a way to make glass products for
the pharmaceutical industry which was
growing very rapidly in italy at the
time
you had a lot of again family-owned
companies and other
companies which were growing in that
market and they needed to find a way to
make it
make these bottles these vials faster
than their competitors
and that's sort of the innovation of
that of that machine called the 3bs
machine
named after the four inventors bostado
that really sort of helped differentiate
them especially against some of their
competitors in germany and also in italy
with those machines they could produce
50 to 60 more than their competitors and
they sort of reinvested all their
profits into that if that had failed
uh you know the company might not have
survived where it is today and it sort
of
helped them gain a foothold in a new
industry which kept growing
and they moved away from providing those
glass models for minor perfume
and moved entirely into this they
actually shut down
the glass bottle the wine bottle company
at that time as well
i think really set the stage for them to
grow
up until the 90s in the 2000s expanded
overseas so as of 2020
uh steven auto was making more than 2
billion
glass vials a year more than 600 million
syringes
and more than 4 billion plastic parts
including for diagnostic tests
so that's sort of the their main
efforts sort of related to covet they
also as i mentioned earlier
are the largest producer of insulin pen
cartridges which is a
another big uh market in 2019
the global pharmaceutical industry
purchased some 12 billion vials
the steven auto group provided more than
two billion of those
might come off a little nerdy but one
thing i find interesting is that i
you know was really drawn to reporting
the story is how they don't just make
the vials or
just the syringes they make the machines
that make those
vials that turn the glass into those
vials that
sterilize them that and then uh you know
can package them at the end
at the end of the process so they're
really involved at every single step of
the way
um which i think is hard to think about
you don't really think about companies
making all those things together
the steven auto group is doing well and
is still family owned
they recorded about 70 million dollars
in net profit and 670 million dollars in
sales in 2019.
in terms of ownership sergio stevenato
who is the son of the founder giovanni
and the chairman of the board emeritus
owns a 68
stake he stepped down a ceo quite some
time ago when he handed over the reins
to his son franco
franco recently stepped on a ceo to
become chairman of the board
he and his brother marco who is vice
chairman
owned the remaining 32 percent of the
company we estimate
sergio's 68 stake to be worth 1.8
billion dollars
with the stakes owned by marcon franco
to be
north of 400 million dollars a piece the
auto group is planning to go public i
think sometimes and sometime in the next
three years
they have some of their banks and
investors trying to push them to go
public earlier especially because of all
the publicity they're getting
from their efforts in covid but i think
they want to sort of take their time so
i think it'll be interesting to see how
they extend their footprint there and
try to collaborate with biotech
companies
before they get a product to market and
you know a good thing about an
interesting thing about their business
which is good for them is that
when they make packaging for you know be
it a drug or a vaccine or anything
that's obviously patented right but
often even after
the pattern expires drug producers tend
to use the same packaging because it's
easier
so they're making money for a long time
you know
the whole lifetime of that pattern and
that even afterwards so obviously going
public is going to
change things from being a family owned
private company
that's been pretty closely run and held
for such a long time
it'll be interesting to see how they
navigate that and how they grow
in the us and india and elsewhere
you